Right now, somewhere out there,
an educator is delivering
a mind-altering lesson to their class.
I want to engage your brains in this.
Chris Anderson: I tried to get
my head around how vast our Earth is.
Logan Smalley: That lesson only reaches
the students in that room.
What would happen if we captured it?
It's a toothed wheel.
LS: What if pro animators
and visualization artists
could bring that lesson to life?
CA: It's a common object
that literally fits one million Earths.
It's got a bunch of notches
and a bunch of teeth.
This was Fizeau's solution --
LS: When that lesson lands,
curiosity is ignited.
CA: It seems impossibly big.
AS: Something interesting happens.
CA: In the great scheme
of things, it's a pinprick.
AS: A door closes on the light beam
that's coming back to his eye.
LS: Then that group of students
is one thought closer
to being what every teacher
hopes their students will become:
a lifelong learner.
AS: Based on the distance
between the two stations --
CA: The quest for knowledge
and understanding never gets dull.
AS: He calculates the speed of light
to within two percent of its actual value.
CA: The more you know,
the more amazing the world seems.
That's the central mission of TED-Ed:
to capture and to amplify
the voice of the world's
greatest teachers.
He does this in 1849.
CA: It's the crazy possibilities,
the unanswered questions,
that pull us forward.
So stay curious.
TED-Ed is really an invitation
to teachers all around the world
to submit their best lessons.
Jordan Reeves: We review each submission
and work with the educators
to refine the lesson and make sure
that they're less than ten minutes long.
From there, we mail out
these portable recording booths.
A teacher pulls up their final lesson,
presses record and can instantly share it
with our animation team.
It's also an invitation to animators.
We are looking for talented animators
to get involved, submit their reels
and help us animate
these incredible lessons.
LS: Right now, there's a gifted educator
somewhere out there
delivering a life-changing lesson.
The TED-Ed team hopes that anyone
who is passionate about education
will help us find that teacher,
capture that moment and amplify it
the way that it deserves to be amplified.